[Music]
I'm Christopher Hine and this week we're
talking about hadou key so that was my
romantic intro hope you guys liked it if
you liked it comment below and tell me
that you liked the Swivl from here to
here that's what we're doing this week
so I'm Chris Ryan we're talking about
Hadopi this week and today we're going
to talk about the Shiro Rio de Torre and
of Shiro kubishimi and the Hadouken
methods for that so I think a lot of
people don't understand why we have the
sheer Rio de so hoping hopefully we're
gonna clear that up today and the ushiro
kubishimi also has a lot of important
stuff in there that it's hard to
understand if you're not used to
studying armed martial arts so if you
only been studying unarmed martial arts
hard to understand why we might have
those techniques and they're useful
we're gonna talk about the basic ways to
get out of those grabs today I'm gonna
get Josh over here we're gonna go to
work Josh alright so today we're talking
about shear Realty Dori and the
shirokuma Shema we're lumping them
together in this video because they have
a tendency to interplay with each other
an awful lot when people are looking at
you share a Ryota Dori they probably
think it's the dumbest attack in history
the reason is because it's holding both
of my wrists from behind and it seems
like there's a whole lot better options
than to grab both of my wrists from
behind then also how would he even get
there how would he get to that position
in the first place right is he just
expecting to come across the guy we
welcome his arms here down his side he's
gonna come up and grab him like that so
oh I was just hanging out with my hands
by my side and he grabbed me right so it
seems really dumb it seems like it's
very unlikely to happen we're not gonna
ever have that situation if he was
behind me strategically a better choice
would be for him to come up and wrap
around me like this right so if he got
behind me coming over into a bear hug is
a better position for him to get so he's
really got me like this now let's
understand the techniques of traditional
two systems which are the the father of
Aikido are based on weapons stuff
they're not based on unarmed grappling
they're based on soldier battlefield
stuff so what would a soldier on the
battlefields answer be to this well it
would probably be this and then I'll
begin staffing this guy and I would stab
him until he bled out and let go of me
that's what I'm looking for now what
would happen pee at a bear hug and you
belt me draw my knife where would he go
well he'd probably immediately go there
now what would he do with this freehand
here
he's probably shoot that up around my
neck and start to try and choke me this
is sushi Roku Mishima what would happen
if I decided to switch the night pan
because this hand that thing's
controlling it and I put it over here to
stab him well he'd probably go back
behind like this and this is a she wrote
real Ted Doherty so there's a very
reasonable progression as to why that
technique happened I'm trying to stab
this guy and he's trying to stop me by
holding my wrists here like this until
you get to a better position and kick me
or whatever it is he's gonna do okay
so that's how that might come if he were
getting if you were already behind me
but what if he were moving behind me so
let's say this guy's attacking me and
I'm moving around here and as I fade out
to this side I decide to cut it right so
I'm gonna cut him because he's real fast
and aggressive and coming all over and
he blocks that bangs like this now if he
didn't do anything else I would just
move my hand I cut him again but if he's
smart he's gonna grab a hold to that
wrist like this so when he grabs my
wrist like this what's he gonna want to
do next improve his position so he's
gonna try to get here behind me like
this that's either gonna be in here Oh
Cooper she man if I don't do anything
about it or if as he starts to move
behind rewind a little bit for me and he
starts to move behind I switched the
knife into this hand he's gonna go into
a Shiro Realtek so that's why he's gonna
end up in either one of these on the
move right so I'm trying to use the
weapon that helped me control the
position as this happens and he's trying
to keep himself from getting stabbed
that's why this position is happening
that's also why we don't have these
common unarmed grappling holds right so
if Josh would just to go into a rear
naked choke so let's say Joshua's behind
me and he goes into a rear naked choke
there's a classic rear naked choke now
cruel win right him bleeding out while
I'm stabbing him in the guts or him
choking me up
question right so I probably got about
10 seconds before I'm gonna go to sleep
who knows how long he's got with his
guts pouring out of his body right so
this is why these classic techniques are
built that way they're built to control
a weapon there's always going to be a
weapon in play in classic Japanese
martial arts because that's the idea
right okay so we have those how am I
going to get free understanding why the
technique of up here so that's why they
attack appears now how am I going to get
free so if I was here and Joshua is a
new Shiro Rio Tet like this this kind of
position first thing I'm probably going
to try and do is get my hands in front
of me is my hands in front of me means I
can possibly use my weapon which is what
I want now as I do that I'm also going
to express kokutei and try and pop my
hands free now if I got here I'm
starting to get into a position of maybe
worked out of that which would be great
if not he'll go to a body hold so I go
here let's say goes to a body hold
that's fine because I can still use my
weapon here right which is probably
gonna lead us back to the other and give
me an opportunity to escape so first
thing I'm gonna try to do is get my
hands in front now let's say I get my
hands in front and this guy's got a good
grip like this so I couldn't pop him
free well I'm gonna shoot off to the
side like this this either gives me an e
Keo here with the knife which is great
I'm cutting across that tricep or if we
were on the other side of this as I came
across I get an e Keo here and get into
a really nice dominant position which is
really really good for me all right now
if he's smart when I tried to pull my
hands in front he's gonna keep them
they're just too strong I can't get in
anywhere so I'm gonna slide up to the
side here and start to break his balance
now understand if I threw them that
would be fantastic
my goal is not to throw it's just to
make a little room so if you made a
little room cool maybe I'll get another
position from here and all kinds of
other things can happen so I'm just
using it to find myself a little space
in time okay
now let's say he's really smart and as I
try to slide to the side he pulled both
my arms up behind my back like this he's
got my arms and now I can't get around I
can't do anything else that's bad what
am I gonna do I'm gonna isolate a hand
I'm gonna roll in here and I get myself
free to use my weapon again so these
techniques are built to clear that
weapon hand so I can get back into a
good position
these are the main Hadopi we're gonna
use I mean they're gonna come to the
inside with the compute a pop free I'm
gonna slide
while she coming around those arms I'm
going to go hip to hip and nudge him
with my hip kokyu nage to get myself
some space or hopefully knock him up
with me or I'm gonna come to the inside
applying essentially I caught the guy as
I as I come out so these are the core
techniques for those Shiro real Ted Dori
and also the kubishimi it works on these
same principles I'm Christopher Hein
thanks for watching
[Music]